So yeah, I I just wanted to chat about
what was your motivations for coming
up with the exhibition and maybe you can
introduce what it is and then can
go a bit deeper about the data itself.
Yeah. ~ so the project is called Unspoken,
Unbroken and it came it came out of this
idea of looking at domestic violence
and what is unseen and what stories are
told,
what's not told. And I wanted to
incorporate visual
art and visual storytelling with
performing arts.
That's what I do, right? I'm a performing
artist,
I'm a dancer, I'm a I teach dance.
I curate dance. but I wanted something
that was more
~ that had different points of entry to be
more legible
Mm-hmm.
for more for a v wider audience.
So that's when the idea of an exhibition
came where there's different things
happening at the same time. ~ they're
still performing arts because that's,
you know, at my heart and I think it's
very strong.
But there's all these other elements that
happen.
and then can people can kind of travel
through them at their own pace,
without having to sit,
you know, in a theater and waiting for
people to ~ explain or show things.
So that's kind of the b basic idea of when
when it started.
And why the topic Femicide?
So my research is around domestic violence
in general.
~ and I have been looking at this for
many,
many years from many different spaces.
I'm also Italian, right? So I have this
experience of what's happening
in Italy versus what's happening here.
and during my research it has come about
that
femicide and the actual you know,
we celebrate women's lives on November
twenty fifth,
right? There's this International Day
Against Domestic Violence.
And on that day we celebrate women who are
not here anymore,
right? Women who actually lost that fight.
~ and so I started to look into it and
it became really fascinating to me how
differently this subject
is taken by different ~ governments.
And in Italy, strangely enough,
because I'm not saying that Italians are
much more intellectually advanced,
but in Italy they have a way of tracking
women killed by mm partners,
right? and so that's a thing. And also in
South America they have that,
right? So if you are someone who kills a
woman because of their gender,
they consider it a hate crime,
right? Like you would kill an LGBTQ.
person, right, that woo that's a hate
crime or a person that's
a different ~ ethnicity than you.
The United States doesn't do that.
The United States doesn't have that
distinction,
right? And so I just started because I I I
was reading about this stuff in Italy.
I wanted to find out what was happen what
was happening in the US
and I realized that's not a thing in the
US.
Mm-hmm.
There is no distinction ~ between,
you know, one homicide or the other
homicide.
So I became fascinated by this idea why
this wasn't a thing.
And I was looking at dat trying to find
data and there is no data.
And then I found, you know, that's how you
and I came to make this project together.
~ I came across this article by ~ these
incredible women researchers
who researched a specific thing.
I met with them and they said,
There there's no data. The data doesn't
exist,
~ because it is not tracked as a hate
crime.
Mm-hmm.
And so we don't really know how many women
are being affected this way,
Hmm.
right? So I was just fascinated by this
idea of not even knowing exactly
how many women have been affected been
lost to the actual
Mm-hmm.
It's a homicide. But of course that also
comes with the idea that
we don't really have specific data about
domestic violence either.
I mean we have a lot of data, but it's not
very super ~ clear because a
lot of women don't or or men, I mean
domestic violence affects everybody.
But it it a lot of people don't even ~
bring it to the to the forefront,
right? So we don't have all this stories.
So the data even domestic violence is not
completely reliable,
but it is there.
There are big organizations all over the
world,
over the United States, that do take care
of those data sets,
so you get them from different spaces,
but not in femicide. And so I thought that
it was like a lack of there
was a there's a gap, right? There's a gap
in the way that I striked and
so I was interested in pursuing it.
~
talking about the data itself,
right, because what we found out is
there's just one person who's
~ collecting all of this data and like
meticulously going through newspapers
and articles and documents to like record
a very thorough ~ data set.
In fact, there's names, there's ~ the
names of the people who
were involved and then also like details
about her and ~ it's very thorough.
So I'm curious to know if the story of
the person who's collecting it itself kind
of influenced ~ any parts
of how you thought about showing the data
I find this work that she's doing Dawn
Wilcox,
right? She I found out through these other
women that are doing this research that
she's a she's originally a nurse.
And I haven't had I mean that's pretty
much what I know,
Mm-hmm.
right? She's a nurse who has I'm assuming
she's impacted somehow
by this and realized that there was a a
gap and she started doing it and
~ to me it's you know it's it's very
important to recognize people who do this
kind of work out of their own time.
and I'm sure it's not easy, right?
To collect this very emotional data and to
keep to to be mindful about what
Alright.
you share. It's very complicated.
So I have a lot of respect for her.
I I briefly spoke to her about our project
to make sure that it was okay.
You know, you know that. But ~ I don't
know,
I feel that
it kind of really resonated with me what
she's doing with what I wanna do,
right? That I wanna give voices to women
who don't have voice or men
Mm-hmm.
who don't have voice, whoever is being
affected.
And that's what she's doing. Like it's a
very you know,
it's only one person, so it can be,
you know, I'm assuming that the data
cannot be completed,
you know, and so you and I had this
conversation about being completely
transparent,
Mm-hmm.
that this is one woman.
Right
or one person, you know, the data comes
not from like these incredibly
~ funded spaces. It comes from one woman
who does this this part-time in her house.
Right. So we don't know how exactly it it
we're transparent.
Mm-hmm.
This is the data that we have.
It's not complete, right? There's missing
information.
But it's very powerful to me. And the
actual act of doing that is for
her to do that. It's an act of
solidarity and is an act of courage and
it's an act of one showing that progress
can be made even by one person,
right? She's finding something that is not
here and she's creating
Hmm.
it and she's continuing to add on to the
stories.
~
Yeah, I mean even in the exhibit I've kind
of found myself ~ telling
the people who were looking at it about
who was collecting it and who was...
and just telling that story as well
because it felt important to include that
in the piece itself.
I agree. It's important because it's
something that is relevant
to another human being, right?
That they're spending this time telling
stories of others and yes,
I yeah, I can't I can't imagine.
I don't know, like every time I spend time
with that with that data,
I I get very emotional. Like any time that
I try to read the stories and
Mm-hmm.
I want to know about them and then I get
really emotional and I get upset and
Th there's like a definitely a visceral
response to it.
So for her to like being so courageous and
maintaining
~ this process cannot be easy,
you know, through the years because she's
been doing it for many years.
~ so yeah, and I and I agree. I also like
to tell this story of her.
Mm-hmm.
Like this is what this woman does.
Like she's taking this on and she's
already taking care of people by being
a nurse and she's doing this extra work,
you know, so yeah.
Yeah, and I mean, what you mentioned
earlier about the emotion aspect of it.
~ I remember you telling me when I sent
you the website and you were going through
it, it ~ did elicit like an emotional
response.
And I felt the same way, right?
Like going through all of these human
stories they're like actual people
who existed and, you know, now no more.
and just information and stories,
other people talking about their
obituaries,
all of this information, I think that's
what
gave that emotional response to the piece
itself,
which is why I'm curious because ~ while
developing the piece,
because we did this in two parts,
right? We did one last year and then an
updated version of it this year.
~ And between that, one of the major
feedback that you had was
to include these stories in the piece,
right? why do you think that is?
Why do you think
including just that element of a person's
story changes it so much.
mean you you said it kind of already,
but it's you know, when you see numbers,
they're just numbers. I can continue
saying,
you know, two in three women or three in
five men have been affected
by domestic violence, but they're just
numbers.
When you see the stories and you like,
my god, this is a person, right?
They had a family, that had dreams,
that, you know, was either very young and
beginning in their life
or had grandchildren. It doesn't matter
where they are in life.
the that there's a heaviness of
recognizing that that's a person.
And so that's why I think it's important.
I think it's another way and this is what
attracted me to this kind of data that
I don't know anything about because again
I'm I don't know how to do it.
~ but the this this this ability to be
both beautiful,
right, because your ~ your project is
beautiful,
to see, right? It's interactive,
right? You can kind of have feel like
you're part of it and then it's
educational
and then it's also human. So to me this
idea that data is not dry,
right? Data comes from people in this
case,
Mm-hmm.
right? So that's what was really important
to me.
And I think by opening up these flowers
and reading even just
the smallest thing about
them, right? Because again, she's only
getting this stuff from yeah,
like you said, from newspapers,
from Facebook posts, whatever.
It gives you a glimpse and it gives you ~
it opens up
to the whole universe that's their lives,
you know, and the people they are in their
lives,
Mm-hmm.
the friends, the family, the children,
right? And that's also an extra layer of
you realize
how impactful this loss
Are not just for that person but for
those.
Mm-hmm.
So I think that's why I wanted to include
the actual stories,
But there's so many success stories that
are also not told or but
we don't pay attention, right?
We only maybe kind of pay attention to
these dramatic things.
But what about all the women and men who
actually have survived
Mm-hmm.
and thrived and created? So that's the
next part.
But again, by humanizing them,
by not making them I'm a survivor of
domestic violence,
I am a lot more than that, right?
so this idea of humanizing people
They are affected by domestic violence.
Those who don't make it, unfortunately,
to bring more awareness, to change
policies,
to to have ~ an educational space where
people can learn how
to have conversations or how to push for
policy policy change,
right? Which is not up to us because we're
artists,
we can't do that, but we can push for it
if we bring enough attention to it.
And then this other side of
you know, honoring those who are making
the effort,
all those workers who every day,
you know, are are there to support the
survivors.
And, you know, one thing that we also did
in this last exhibition,
we had information on all these
organizations,
right? All the organizations are New York
based,
but some that were national, where you can
get help,
Mm-hmm.
where you can get support, you know,
because that's I think when I speak to
them,
when I speak to these organizations,
that is the one thing that they really
want out there.
How do you reach us? Do you know we exist?
Like we're here. women women,
Right.
men, young people that need help to try to
get this information out there
as much as possible so that they know that
they're not alone.
So it wants to be a space for many
different things.
that comes from what whatever my research
is going,
you know, and yeah.
Hmm.
talking about your research,
and you do a lot of performance-based
stuff,
right? And even this exhibit involved a
performative element to it.
~ the flowers on the wall, and every 10
minutes,
Mm.
I think it's called, right? So every 10
minutes,
the person kind of gets up and takes a
flower off the wall.
And you see some information behind it,
how do you think the context of the piece,
it being performative, what do you think
that adds to someone looking at
it from the outside?
I i I think again it adds immediency and ~
it makes it real,
right? So that piece was born out of the
~ the general global data that we have,
right? Because again we don't have it in
the United States.
So the global average of women killed by a
partner or family member is
one every ten minutes. That's kind of the
UN
Mm-hmm.
estimated idea. And if you think about it,
if you actually sit there and think about
it,
one every ten minutes, how many people is
that?
Hey.
So the idea is, okay, we're here we're in
this gallery from 11 AM to 8 PM.
By getting up every 10 minutes and taking
these flowers and putting
on the ground and you see the
accumulation.
It's blatant that, my God,
Mm-hmm.
we just lost this amount of women or men
or young people.
while we're here in the gallery or while
we're at work,
Hmm.
right? And so the idea was to make a to to
be present
for these moments, right? Which is kind of
hard for those women and people
who are taking the flower out,
but also to honor it and to recognize the
the passage of time and
Hmm.
how consistent it is. And what I did,
because again our data is limited,
I actually under the the flowers I put the
mode of of death,
right? So how would this woman were
killed,
Mm-hmm.
which I took from Dawn because I wanted
to bring to light that
gun control and femicide has a very deep
connection in the US.
~ and most of those ~ most of those
Mm-hmm.
~ labels were were gun.
guns, right? There's other modes,
Hmm.
but that was the main one. ~ because
they're intertwined.
Right? They're not this this these issues
do not live on their own,
Right
right? So if we figure out a way to maybe
control gun availability,
Hmm.
it might solve some of these issues,
right? So that's what I wanted to bring.
and then yes
Yeah, it's it's a way of witnessing or pay
memory,
~ and and and really str yeah,
to to get a almost like ~ I don't know,
like a a gut sensation out of okay,
Mm-hmm.
I've been here for two hours and you know,
eight women have gone. And that
realization,
Hmm.
right, to be to understand that it's an
ongoing
~ an ongoing problem.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, no, that's,
you think about, like, a statistic and
it's just,
one person every 10 minutes and you,
read it in, like, a paper or a report or
something and you just pass by it.
But I feel like, I think, yeah,
like you said, giving time for someone to
experience what that really means.
Yeah, I think that's a really
incredible...
And while I was there as well,
I could see the wall getting more bare,
the flowers coming down over time.
It feels like you get the impact of it by
being present in it.
Exactly. Yeah, and you know, you say you
touched on something that's very important
that actually kind of inspired this whole
idea is that again,
if I read it it's one thing, if I see it's
another.
If I read it is one thing, if I feel it is
Mm-hmm.
And this is why I do believe that the arts
are powerful,
right? For this. They make you feel it.
Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm.
The numbers are not gonna make you feel it
unless they're used in a s a certain way.
And domestic violence is one of those
things that is so I'm not
I'm not saying normalized, but in a way it
is normalized that we kind of take it,
Mm-hmm.
yeah, well, you know, a woman is killed.
Was there the first question that is
asked,
did the husband kill her or did the
boyfriend kill her?
That's the first question. And if you
think about it,
Right
it's like, well, yeah, but that's not a
good thing,
right? So I think that and also the other
thing that I noticed is like,
you know, no one is pro domestic violence.
Who who who's who do you know that goes
around saying domestic violence is good?
Hmm.
Nobody. You have people that say I'm pro
guns.
Hmm.
You have people that say I don't care,
I can smoke whenever I want, you know,
but nobody says I'm for domestic violence,
yet here we are now moving forward.
So I think that that's the other thing.
Hmm.
These numbers are so staggering and so
scary that even
the the best intentioned people don't
wanna kind of relate to it.
You know, they're just like and yeah,
they're too hard to digest.
and and it's also the normalization of it.
You know, I speaking with all these
amazing ~ pioneers around domestic
violence,
the the biggest ~ win that we've had in
the last twenty years
is that domestic violence is finally
recognized as a crime.
Because that wasn't even the case twenty
years ago,
Mm.
right? So it's very slow progressing,
but I think yeah.
I think we need more ~ more data like
this,
more visual data, more more more data that
makes you feel something.
And that yeah.
Right.
Yeah, even the digital piece that I helped
with,
even though it's a digital, like it's just
a website,
right? But the fact that the context it
was in was a physical space where there
were
other people engaging with it,
that kind of, I guess, forces you to talk
to other people and also get
to know more about it. And there's
something about that context
of it being showcased that way,
I know that we were talking about the
website living on Wade's website,
the visualization, but there's obviously a
difference between that
Totally.
and exhibiting it, right? So I'm curious
what your thoughts are about that.
No, I agree. there is there it's that
community based thing that's important,
right? And ~ of course having you
explaining what it is,
right? So that they they have this idea
that it's been created by a human
and not by an AI, right? And that there's
all this research behind it.
But also, yes, you you play with play with
it,
meaning you move around with it and you
with someone else and
you start a conversation or you don't
reali like like it's kind of
It's it's a very beautiful thing to do,
right? And yeah, in the context of where
you are,
it's about community, it's about
conversations.
Like you said, you know, I I can have it
on my website which I wanna
do just because I want it to be
accessible.
This is the other thing that I really want
to push the company forward
Mm-hmm.
is accessibility. This this this last ~
gallery that we did was free,
right? Everything was free. The
performances were free,
Right.
the wine was free, everything was free.
~
Because when you go to see, you know,
when I do a lot of productions in
performance,
I have to rent a theater, I have to I it's
a it's a different kind of expense.
You can still do it free, right?
But there's something about having
accessibility to this kind
Hmm.
of research. So that's the reason why I
wanna have it on the website
so that people can see it in their own
home wherever they are and it
Mm-hmm.
can reach a wider audience. But I am I
have a
all the intentions in the world to
continue presenting this kind of work
in a gallery setting or wherever I am
alongside whatever else
is happening because it is powerful and
it's another way to enter the
conversation.
Mm-hmm.
This is the thing that I w I've been
struggling as a as a performing artist.
I mean I understand why the work that I
present is you know talking about domestic
violence, right?
I curated. So I know that, you know,
I'm engaging artists who are researching a
topic around domestic violence,
or they use certain, you know,
~ music that's created, but I get it,
but it can be very abstract, right?
Mm-hmm.
So it needs some kind of explanation for
people to see you need to write
to write it down, unless it's blatantly
using words,
right? So but again it has a very visceral
and beautiful or
Okay.
effect on people. That's one way of doing
it.
I couldn't just do that anymore.
It's to me it's not enough. ~ and this is
why,
Hmm.
you know, you come in. You have this way
of doing art and data
and accessibility and research that's
aligned to what I'm doing.
Mm-hmm.
But some other people may react and
respond to your work and
to the way you present it more clearly
than what I'm doing.
Hmm.
Right. And so I think that's exciting for
my own
~ artist artistic projection,
right? That I'm allowing I'm really
opening up to different ways of doing what
Mm-hmm.
I love. ~ we had a this yeah,
Hmm. That's wonderful, yeah.
we had this wonderful singer, right?
And she curated the whole entire set.
Two hour set. Amazing. I can't believe
that she sang for two hours.
That was okay.
Hmm.
But she curated it around the topics of
the ~ of the exhibition,
right? And that is again, it's easier
because you hear it.
Mm-hmm.
There are words. Right. So you you
immediately have and there's music,
Right.
right? You have a different reaction,
but it's it's more immediate. ~ and yeah,
every ten minutes I thought it was very
immediate because it w y you're right
there,
Yeah.
right? You see it. But then with other
works you have to reflect on your
Mm-hmm.
own and you know and
We had those we have some of those ~
workshops where we were making flowers
and adding them on, right? That's another
way of of being part of the event.
We have a couple of workshops,
like physical workshops and live music
workshops.
So I'm just trying to figure out ways to
keep people engaged and meet them where
they feel the most ~ that's most
beneficial to them.
Because at the end of the day,
Right.
honestly, and I I talk about this a lot.
This is a space of community, of
storytelling,
of truth telling, but it's also a place of
joy.
It's not specifically a place where we
just wanna come and like be depressed.
Mm-hmm.
We just wanna acknowledge the data and we
want to have conversations and
Mm-hmm.
we want to come up with ideas,
but then we want to move, we wanna dance,
we wanna be in community, you know,
so that's what I'm playing with.
I'm trying to make that legible so that
People don't read, my god, another thing
about domestic violence,
I'm just gonna I can't de I'm too
depressed.
Right.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. No, I get that.
That's lovely. And I mean, ~ when you
mentioned ~ the fact about meeting people
where they are, which I think that's where
there's these two ends of the spectrum,
right? One is completely performance,
and you have to be there present
physically to experience it.
And then the other end is ~ raw statistics
and graphs that maybe you're
Mm-hmm.
on a subway, and you
scroll through it on your phone.
So you can't really expect someone who's
in a subway to be present
in a performance. And the other way also
holds true.
Right.
So I guess, that's a really nice way of
seeing,
meeting people where they are and having
different ways of reaching them based
on how they can access the information.
And that's what I mean. It's not,
you know, I'm not trying to be like I,
you know, I'm meeting their level of
anything.
I just what do you want? How do you ha
what is the best way for you
Mm-hmm.
to receive this information? Right.
Hmm.
I know people who don't like going to
museums,
right? And I know people that love going
to museum,
performances, non performances.
So I feel that it's exciting to figure out
how to have a varied community
of people, different ages, different
background coming together and talking
about something that's affecting them.
I had this group of very adorable senior
citizens who came from Harlem
and we had a great time. We had you know
we had a workshop and arts
Mm-hmm.
and music and dance, but then we spoke
about this
~ the topics, right? And they were
interested and they they they they were
relating
them to where their lives was,
right? But maybe for them
it wasn't the same approach as,
you know, the young kids who come for the
happy hour who have a different idea
w w what they where they are in life,
right? So I think I am very excited to
figure out that along
the community that grows, ~ what what are
people what what what
do people wanna hear, wanna see,
how do we how do we create this space
that's really accessible to everybody?
And yeah.
Yeah, that's amazing. I think ~ that's a
good place to sort
of end this conversation.